[Music]
in a multiverse full of infinite
possibilities even the lamest ideas must
exist
which is why in a long enough timeline
disney had to make something like oh i
don't know a hawkeye series
hawkeye
the series
you've seen clint barton lose his mind
to loki's staff lose his family to the
blip and lose his best friend to the
ground now get ready for a new adventure
about the time he lost his hearing more
cookie please thank you lost some very
important dry cleaning witnesses
captured cell phone footage of a masked
assailant fleeing the scene and lost all
of his patience
as far as i'm concerned we're in this
together
tell her she hurt your feelings but
apologize can you believe the avengers
have never lost a fight when hawkeye is
with him it's like the hulk's lucky
purple underwear you can't just put him
on any shaft you know
remember hawkeye he's old now and the
most overt avenger has literally heard
enough of your ship
is that all time
i can do this all
did you turn your hearing aid off and
now that jeremy renner would rather be
rocket than knock in
he's passing the bow to kate bishop
she's a milestone of representation as
the mcu's first hero who thinks hawkeye
is cool can you sign this you're kind of
my favorite avenger this heir to the
name is a clueless rich girl who's
really into archery and branding your
problem is branding it's a very hard
brand to tell i've been thinking about
your branding issue you need a more
recognizable costume it's the branding
issue i'm telling you but don't worry
kinda sucking is one of hawkeye's main
qualifications k should easily slide in
the role going forward
the she wax her pants that definitely
sounds like something rich girls would
do you do know she went to the same high
school as winnipotro right
watch clint and kate work together to
find who killed her father's brother's
nephew's cousin's former roommate oh
sorry i mean her mother's fiance's
estranged uncle who loves drama and
helping them crack this super important
case are the avengers
just kidding they would never helping
them are sea teamers like sober jack
sparrow
kate's wealthy parents who you just know
are criminals call it the arrow
principle some larpers the heroes look
down on which is rich considering
hawkeye larps as an avenger lucky the
pizza dog who's cute but let's face it
he's no airbud gonna eat that pizza all
day you're gonna start hitting some
three-pointers elena who keeps up her
streak of making the audience wonder why
isn't this about yelena instead and
linda cardellini has the chillest wife
on the planet who will assume is cool
with clint spending christmas eve
drinking with a hot rich 22 year old who
idolizes him and looks like a young
version of her dude she's ex-shield
she's gonna find those texts and they uh
do not look good
prepare for the most suit obsessed tv
show since suits told nobody about this
suit wait what about the suit i told you
that suit was bad news yeah i'll give
you the suit did you get the suit suit
suit
suit suit suit suit suit suit suit where
clint must atone for the time he
butchered half the criminal underworld
and also his haircut hunting him down
his echo a mob lieutenant whose hearing
loss gives her a superhuman tolerance
for the word bro wiki wiki bro
it worked bro we got you now bro are you
making it so tough on us bro and in a
reveal they teased for five weeks
straight vincent d'onofrio returns as
the kingpin who appears to have spent
his time off camera becoming a hawaiian
pimp he'll step out of the multiverse
only to get worked by just about every
main character in the mcu's answer to
darth maul getting sliced in round one
of the lightsaber playoffs i'm not
saying the return of the netflix
characters has been a dud so far
but danny rand just changed his facebook
invite from going to maybe
so tune in for this family-friendly
shane black riff where the weapons
aren't lethal the guys aren't nice and
in true marvel fashion there's no kiss
kiss or bang bang but it still gives us
some passable action
[Applause]
[Music]
decent quips hey look that one's you no
it's katniss everdeen and a fun new hero
oh wow didn't i didn't realize we were
supposed to bring guns even though you
could have had twice the fun by reading
the comics it's based on or reading
about the jeremy renner app or reading
about the other marvel musical we wish
we could see now in previews at the
foxwoods theater the event that will
redefine the broadway spectacular i'm
going to tell my kids that this was no
way home
starring
sterling archer
assistant to the regional hawkeye
it was a one-eyed street raised golden
puppy pizza eater mom you have failed
the city captain stabbin
florence the pew florence the pew
russian little sister loves macaroni
silent but deadly
quasi the clown a twitch influencer
still a cop
i thought you loved all animals mr
ventura and what a week straight up
getting beat in the face looks like are
we sure they don't have healing powers
ronin with the homies
[Music]
world's greatest archers can you even
salmon ladder bro
queen takes bishop checkmate
they call me mr tibbs
i'm not an actor but i play one on tv
there is no spoon there is a fork
let's get dangerous
you like krabby patties don't you
squidward